cheerleader this morning this is
Sydney's kiss we are doing a different
sort of give back this morning Kyle this
is a random give back and we're gonna be
speaking to this person through the
radio they are a passenger in a car
right now right and they don't know this
is about to happen and this is someone
who has lost someone very close to them
and she's been struggling with this loss
for a while now a woman I'm speaking to
she has her three children in the car
with her yeah she's wearing a light blue
top and she thinks she's on her way to a
spa day Michelle we are talking to you
and I know how hard you've been
suffering lately you've faced what no
parent should ever have to go through
and that is the loss of your beautiful
19 year old son Blane this happened only
recently on the 1st of December last
year and her world was turned upside
down when she learned that Blane was
involved in a freak accident at work he
came off the back of a tractor and he
had very little room to move and he
passed away there that day I know and
there are times you know in life when
tragedy strikes very unexpectedly and
your emotions have a hard time catching
up and I know Michelle that you have
been struggling to deal with this and I
know that Blane was such a kind natured
boy he was a family man who was never
afraid of showing his affection for you
he adored you he adored his family and
his girlfriend Victoria but I'm sure
he's watching out for you and your
beautiful children crystal Jessica and
it's all very overwhelming for her she
is facing that pressure of having to go
back to work and she's not ready Ron she
can't cook you know life still gotta go
on bills have to be paid that's right
so this is what we'd like to do for your
Michele and you know we have to thank
the huge generosity of Clarendon homes
here because for six months we would
like to pay your mortgage so that you
don't have to rush back to work and you
can take your time to grieve properly
and we also know that plane was doing
all the outdoor renovations for you and
Tamaki's memory we'd like to finish off
those outdoor renovations with $5,000
and work memory of him Michele you there
oh it's very tough it's very difficult
accessibility to read these stories of
other people listening to these stories
you're just the emotion that we feel
can't even begin to imagine how you're
going through we just can't but he
sounded like such a great it's a great
kid
when a penny shop those things want to
give you that time
you